so you're getting very emotional because  this is serious yes of course I'm  serious white privileged male why do you  have to rape is a woman to kill a male  rapist when that male could just not  rape in the first place I know wouldn't  that be great yeah wouldn't it be  [ __ ] great yeah do you know why  wouldn't it be great if men didn't rape  yeah  we all agree rape is bad you think I'm  here saying away with it they don't get  away with it away with it no they get  away without this [ __ ] campus  all right zip it when you say men get  away with it we allow men to get off  scot-free with rape it's not true and  you absolve people with personal  responsibility these are the worst  Society some you're talking to someone  who comes from Canada we have a  parliamentary  appreciate it man thank you hopefully  there you go